2022 is a year that seared into the
memories of the people of wennington the
village on the outskirts of London
that's come to define the devastating
impact of our warmer climate
in total 19 homes were destroyed by the
wildfires in July
visit the Village today and not much has
changed this was the outside main wall
of my house which existed Shane Turner
is one of those who lost everything and
is now trying to rebuild his house
knowing the same could happen again
it does worry me yeah and and hence the
reason that you take the steps that you
do we're looking at reducing the amount
of Shrubbery which we had around the
garden and trying to reduce the amount
of Timber fencing that there was because
that's what it tracked up literally to
get from the bottom of the garden to the
top of the garden in the first place
it's thought the fire here began after a
compost heap spontaneously combusted the
same day the UK saw its hottest
temperature ever of 40.3 degrees Celsius
this chart shows how the annual average
temperature has risen since records
began breaching 10 degrees for the first
time last year
what happened here was clearly
unprecedented but the fear is the
conditions that led to it are now going
to be much more frequent under a natural
climate without the burning of fossil
fuels an exceptionally warm year would
have been expected once every 500 years
but now the Met Office says it's likely
every three to four years
when I started doing research on climate
change in the mid late 90s so back then
we knew that the climate was warming but
the kind of Records we've seen been
broken since then it's something that
yes indeed it surprised me
back then we didn't expect to see uh
summer temperatures above 40 degrees in
the UK
former firefighter Steve dudney used to
be stationed commander in Wellington he
says a sea change is now needed in how
fire services are trained and equipped
if they're to cope with our changing
climate all of the reasons that caused
the fires last year are going to come
back again this year and in subsequent
years and I think people just need to be
awake to it and aware that this isn't
going to go away anytime soon so change
needs to come from change needs to come
fast probably quicker then it can be
physically managed a stark warning in a
climate that's now full of them either
Bennett Sky News in Wellington greater
London